[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
this
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello
are we live
looks like we're live hey everybody
how's it going hopefully you can hear me
you can hear phil uh
the game uh it's destiny 2 it's their
30th anniversary uh
content pack i guess is what they're
calling it
uh this big ass celebration of 30 years
of bungie uh
which is uh man how crazy is that that
they're dropping this like the day
before halo infinite
this is bananas it's bananas there's a
lot going on it's a good time to be a
fan of bungie slash
games made
by bungie originally
um yeah man we're going to be checking
out this content drop uh the so the
funny thing is it puts you when you load
up the game it immediately puts you into
the new content which is cool
uh i was in the middle of setting up the
stream
so the game
totally uh
booted me out of the of the activity
because i was afk
so i'm currently
i'm currently still uh trying to
i need to do it
so i think phil phil here uh by the way
i'm john luke that's phil you can hear
over there hey hey
um phil's gonna join me and then um
we're gonna go and do that in a second
we also got david amadi who's gonna join
us in a second
uh i think he's currently like running
through it right now
yeah he's actually capping the opening
for us so we can flip it over to the uh
to put it on gamespot i believe
so you can see it if you can't run the
dares right away you can get a sense of
what they're like it's pretty cool it's
not it's a bit it's a bit menagerie it's
a bit uh
um
leviathan what's the the gauntlet in the
leviathan it really it has a game show
vibe and like zur is literally narrating
it like he's a game show host
so it's pretty good it's pretty good
time it's pretty it's already pretty
funny the horse plays a large role
the horse talks a lot like you hear a
lot of like horse sounds
so it's cool so far i'm into it
yeah okay so check this out i um so i
did just finish the dare and i got the
first reward bundle where are you um
and it looks like the street where
is part of it so let's see beanie
now we were talking about the bee i'm
tracking it down right now
okay it is in the hunter stuff it's the
streetwise cloak and you get it after
you finish your first air so let's go
let's do your first stairs and get you
okay yeah yeah yeah
let's do it
oh wait i gotta oh actually give me one
second i don't know you're good you're
good
my mailbox has got to be overflowing at
this point yeah yeah you're all set i'm
gonna double check that the
uh game audio is is is enough um sounds
good
two other things i discovered real quick
since i finished it for there um so
first you get the uh yellowhorn
um
exotic quest from zur right after your
first there so i have that second
there's a
um quest for the halo
um pistol the magnum yeah which is
called hang on let me find out what's
its name that's also an exotic it's also
available from sir i don't have it yet i
think oh okay i wonder if i can here i
can go to my collection and try and find
there you go good idea
i'm back i just finished the the opening
thing whatever we're live i got it
oh [ __ ] okay
i'm a little bit i'm just like munching
on breakfast right now
on the stream
oh that's good to go for it
oh yeah okay third thing the halo battle
rifle or what
is approximately the halo battle rifle
is also
was in my first set of rewards from the
dare wow nice
it's a legendary and it comes with
uh different perks blunt execution
rounds damaging nearby component or
combatants with melee abilities
dramatically increases handling and
damage it's the freaking
halo triangle you punch a guy and then
your gun is better because you got to
punch him and throw grenades at him oh
they call it the
bxr that's really good that's a really
that's so good
um
[Laughter]
oh that's excellent having played an ass
load of halo in the last two weeks this
is just like could not be better
oh that's so cool
damn
uh
all right dude yeah if you guys are good
i just want to get into it um so david
uh as uh i was telling the chat um i was
like setting up the stream still as i
got pulled into the activity so i
actually got booted for uh
being afk so i actually know
so i gotta go run into it it's good yeah
yeah
oh yeah just give me let's definitely
get her running yeah
are you uh are you joined in on me
oh yeah sure
yeah we're just gonna we're gonna do it
because we need to go we gotta finish
the dare to get all these quests so
yeah you guys let me know when you're
when you're ready on me and we'll
run run it up
uh are you like in orbit because it says
not enough space in fire team right now
i'm in the tower uh yeah we're in the
tower keeping up okay okay tower's full
probably that's fine
okay i can join you guys when you hit uh
orbit okay gotcha yeah yeah
two seconds while i make sure my
my vault is or my by the way there is a
uh
a shader you can grab with bright zest
in the uh eververse store uh oh yeah
yeah 30th anniversary it's it's
nice-looking there's also if you go to
the store a free gift of bright dust for
the 30th anniversary oh no bottom right
hand totally right oh look at that right
there yeah pro tip everybody go uh oh
700 brake dust tell you yeah that's
pretty good okay also this shader is
nice i'm going to apply this right i i
like
bruce yeah i like it i'm a fan of it um
it's like steel and blue and
oh and then um if you go to the bright
desk section there's another one as well
yeah brunish reed
that one's that one
but uh still cool but yeah yeah new new
stuff you know i always
i'll always grab the shaders yeah every
for sure yeah let me let me quickly
apply that to my i want this vr in my
inventory
oh all right so i'm going to remind me
to infuse up this fell winter theater
i want to change up my
my look a little bit
yeah we got to do a little fashion
yeah well the uh
i had a fashion but it doesn't work with
this current shader it was my spooky my
spooky fashion
let's see
um
we got to get bounties and stuff i
haven't played this game in a few days i
have forgotten how everything works oh
yeah
a hundred percent
i think i usually
do no not that upgrade modules
alrighty
oh my god stand up how do i stand
all my buttons are weird
yeah it's those weeks of playing halo
and you're like what how do you
everything just feels strange
phil are you on your uh hunter
yeah
nice okay
and yeah
i was just telling john luke if you
finish your dare you get a pack from zur
and it's got all the street wear clothes
in it from
the trailers and stuff including the
beanie so what
yeah
it's just i want that beanie
yeah it's free junk so
oh my god
i had too much stuff
i'm just like throwing together an
outfit it looks okay
maybe
also apologies if you can hear my
neighbors doing what looks like
uh woodworking outside
[Laughter]
apologies if you can hear me eating to
be honest it's like
i can't hear you eating it's just when
when you talk i can tell you in your
mouth
but otherwise you're fine
sick
anyway let me know when you're ready
phil i know i'm sorry no no no no no no
you're fine i'm i'm uh
i'm just applying
i'm trying to find the right outfit here
that's gonna
make some tough calls
throw some stuff away let's see
that's pretty all right
i want that br i want it right now
that's the solid little outfit i think
maybe i just checked the helmet
see if i can get better
all right
okay okay
okay we good
yeah all right cool we're gonna head to
orbit
david go ahead and join on us
donovan says show me the gala horn i
would love to see the gala we're working
on it we're working on it we'll get
there right away um
okay
go ahead and join on me
yeah you didn't come with me that's
weird
no
i don't think i ever got actually oh you
never
i put on my hat ghost okay there we go
also it looks like i'm peeking maybe in
the audio let me
hold on guys me
so yeah the gallery is going to take a
quest it's going to take like that's
better to go for it
oh they rearrange the shaders
i think chris is online do we want him
to join us for the for the dares
we could we could see if phoenix wants
to come too
yeah yeah if you guys want to uh hop
that in so yeah so let's see here we got
uh i just have to complete a round and
then i have to go
fly out for the wolves talk to
sean han um
yeah
probably for the galaxy
did you call him sean han
oh i did
shawhan
[Laughter]
i love that honestly
[Laughter]
let's go i can't read i can't read i i
like don't look at how to actually
pronounce something i just like see it
and i immediately just say what the
first thing that comes to my head i did
that last night where i like ron is like
great
i said a name
uh in like a show we were watching and
my girlfriend just turned to me and said
uh that first name was wrong and that
last name was wrong you did not say that
name correctly at all
okay all right chris just joined on us
you did sick
are you talking i'm in the slack because
i no i didn't i just sent a um a hail
mary invite
okay nice he uh he bit so
cool uh
unfortunately i don't know phoenix's uh
thing if you guys want to try and get
that in real quick but otherwise we can
start up and they can join after
cool
oh he's downloading the update oh okay
we'll we'll start it without him then
and
they can join after cool let's do this
there's a fraternity thing because i
need to do this
and i'm sure the uh the chat here just
wants to be uh
seeing cnns content
i want to get to that dungeon i don't
know where it is
i think it's i think that's that they
have to go talk to uh shaw han about
yeah maybe i see that's what i was
thinking it was like maybe you've got to
do a quest line to get to the dungeon
and within the dungeon is where you get
the keller horn which would be sick i
would love that i wonder i mean i i
assume
the dungeon would be gallahorn
and i hope
infinite neigh
[Music]
i love it
we're just like going straight there are
a lot of black holes in the solar system
i've learned
um and here's the new one
anyway we'll talk about laura later
[Laughter]
are you going to go for the full uh
thorn set is there a full thorn set
i haven't paid too much attention oh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah there is there's a full thorn set
yeah the thumbnail you made is the thumb
set oh is that what that is oh yeah that
stuff looks sick i would like that
loading in
there we go
all right hopefully my gear is okay uh
it doesn't really matter yeah it'll be
fun
look at that horse
i love it hell yeah all right let's
let's see how this battle rifle handles
i got a legendary trace rifle
nice
what is it
um is it the spartan
the spartan laser that'd be sick
is it i don't know maybe i don't know do
you know you can inspect me um after
and you guys can see
because i'm not sure
it is dope
looking okay uh i realize i'm definitely
not set up for champions
oh yeah i forgot all about champions
they're pretty um they're pretty weak
though they're not like uh nightfall
champions or whatever
they're like spin the wheel yeah spin
spin the wheels spin the wheel yeah
wheel of eternity turn turn turn tell us
the lessons like that eric andre skit
where the wheel just keeps spinning will
hit spin
i immediately thought of uh
i think it's
um tiny two adventures or or
whatever yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it was in there i wasn't sure what
it all meant but it did exist in my head
oh what's this uh
a power up super energy collected yeah
yeah so if you run over those those
little things you get little power-ups
some of them are super energy some of
them are
will like boost your speed make you go
real quick
oh okay um
ability energy etc and so on they change
over time it seems like too
what's that horse star horse star horse
what a [ __ ] name dude
star horse he noticed our progress
this one over here is speed if you want
to come over here look okay yeah
increasingly
there's a little uh notification that
appeared yeah that's that's a bonus get
the speed bonus it's sick it makes you
jump oh and it makes you jump right
oh that's oh we gotta defuse bombs
everybody died at sea i'm coming
there we go
oh is that a scorch cannon excellent yes
there are scorch games also
i'm trying to diffuse this mine
all right there we go
he's still up
oh that's weird i thought we got a
i think another set spawned in
yep here's another set
nice
i really know how the score works but
seems like we're doing well
that was a sound
i legit thought my [ __ ] game crashed
did you guys hear there just now
no it is a time for a preposterous
obstacle course
that thing will launch you toward that
spinny thing up there and you want to
try and make it through yeah you got to
time it yeah okay interesting
it's hard it's hard to time is it me i
don't hear any game sound uh i could
bump it a little bit i might have it too
low let me let me also we also talked
over sir i regretted it after i started
doing it oh shh
i've about the game audio hopefully you
guys can hear it now did i time it right
i did
that was perfect okay what is that thing
what's up there
what's up where
where did you go
you went through that is a purple thing
up there did you get up there what
happened no i just went through the
thing
what
[Laughter]
what is the point of going through that
thing
because there's a path below it
oh i think it's like a shortcut
oh oh there's it's a super it's a super
spawn okay
yeah i got like a bunch of super
energies here yeah it's a super energy
it's a spiffy
super energy thing okay good it's oh so
if you miss it you just have to go
normally is that what happens yeah yeah
there's a regular
i see it's i've felt i fell down there
before and it's it's this is the first
time that i went through the little
super path and you've got this way
faster
this is all crushy and spooky which is
actually hilarious
and there's like rushing water
it's very cool i want to take you back
through there
but yeah you did the cool you did that
crisper kind of already answered it in
the chat but uh yeah massacre was asking
uh isn't this free uh yeah this
particular mode we're playing right now
is free this part is yes the dungeon
isn't free
right but we have not unlocked it yet we
haven't unlocked it yet
and i think of some of the stuff like in
the wheelhorn oh i'm gonna spin the
wheel spin the wheel
sorry i mean interrupt you i just wanted
no no you're fine
i appreciate that the blueberries were
patient and let jean luke spin the wheel
it was like they knew like they're just
like hanging out with us
oh you can't get on the horse oh my god
[Laughter]
oh my god
uh massacre let me know if the game
volume is any better i'm seeing levels
and it seems like it's level appropriate
but you you let me know you have you
have a better sense of that in me
oh
i gotta i gotta find the lore about all
this this is so weird this is like all
universe stuff they're talking about
dude the legendary trace rifles are like
kind of a game changer
oh i need to get one of those
i got one from um running the dares
earlier so you might be able to get one
uh after this hopefully
they're pretty cool it's like it's
basically just like the prometheus will
not permit these ones but it's basically
just like any other trace rifle except
it doesn't take up uh an exotic slot
which is like oh okay
yeah nice
and i mean i don't know if you're pvp
but like for these like ads and stuff
like they're doing it's doing okay
i'm enjoying this uh battle rifle it's
not like
my favorite gun ever but it is cool
the like halo inspired battle rifle yes
oh nice do you have it equipped right
now honestly
yeah it's uh it's in the energy slot
we're in the secondary slot i'm kind of
yeah
battler oh that's cool just go all in
and make it look exactly like the battle
rifle yeah
homages are always [ __ ] nice though
like oh yeah i love that stuff and you
can tell you it's you immediately know
what it is
yeah there's like a lot of love in that
design
there's bomb tender
what the hell is this stupid doing out
here okay yeah grab that take a deer
core yeah and i'm gonna look at that boy
it's literally a bomb oh that's sick
what was the um what was the activity
from
the um
osiris's
sundial sundial thing yeah yeah remember
with it
with the cabal guys and you had to throw
bombs at them yeah oh yeah that's what
this reminds me of
sorry i can't think and shoot at the
same time
yeah it's almost like a hammer dawn in
like bomb forms yeah a little bit
you know what i mean
it's also hilarious
whenever like destiny adds little things
like that i always like like whether if
it's um
scorch cannons or in rise of iron it was
like the
not the axe or is that what you can call
it it's like a battle axe right
that stuff was was really dope yeah i
don't know what the official term for
that weapon is
but
you got any more course
yeah i just blasted the guy in the
middle
[Laughter]
i just noticed one of our guys names are
uh our rando's
[Laughter]
uh obviously that's a reference to the
delicious uh bowl of nuts that kalas
gives you in the you know
parade
nothing nothing else
oh did they just spawn a [ __ ] tank
yes
oh my god i love that
oh i'm gonna die oh this is upsetting
all right i'm good
i love these orbital bombs these things
are sick
put these in the game everywhere
oh man snipers all over the place
there we go
yeah
excellence
got that sound
the horse
step off these little plates
because
oh
yeah someone pointed out uh there there
were two hive symbols
on the on the wheel
and what the difference between those
were
uh i think one is taken hive and then
one is
um regular height oh okay that makes
sense look i have the star horse's favor
what is that
oh you picked the um
so you know those three plates or
whatever yeah you're supposed to like
guess what the next enemy's going to be
and if
you chose correctly there was actually
confetti that blew up around you yeah
yeah i actually got star horses penalty
because i chose wrong
and
i have no idea what that means i found
like the better path through that maze
and i got a bunch of super energy for it
oh nice
oh damn then it kicked me off this moon
this cliff though
so yeah there are fun little paths
through there
that's
wow destiny's still thing damn right it
is uh yeah it is
yeah it's not playing destiny right now
you are missing out it is great it's
better than it's ever been
people still play destiny like yeah dude
it's been it's been seven years like
roughly two million people still play
destiny all the time like jesus oh [ __ ]
here they
waiting
go
look at this guy
he's got like a cool samurai thing going
on
yeah he's got a little banner flapping
behind him like oh oh
oh yeah look at that yeah okay the
longer i play with this br the more i
enjoy it it's really cool
it just feels like it fires fast it
feels good it feels accurate there's not
a lot of
not a lot of recoil on this thing
it's just a good little pulse rifle
oh champion in the back here i have no
champion mods on i don't know if anybody
else does
no you don't want
oh we're
i'm watching chris just go to [ __ ]
town on this boss with the shield he's
just bashing him
yeah let's wail him and see if we can't
get it oh christ
all right yeah there we go
too many snipers
oh
oh there was a plane it was uh one of
those threshers that blew me up
brendan hey brandon what's up thanks for
joining
hey hey
playing some destiny 2
i'm very excited to see these weapons
yeah man i want to take this vr in the
crucible this thing feels great
what are we gonna do this guy he's like
in a shield what's going on
uh you gotta break him we gotta get some
bombs i think yeah i haven't seen any
oh uh
uh yeah i got it
cool
another unstoppable champ over here
oh god
damn it
all right got him
yeah boss is damageable now
that hurt
oh yeah
i'm just swinging away
he's got a stomp that sets you on fire
that's cool
it doesn't send you flying it just burns
the area around you oh can we get them
can we get them
no you jump down
now we can still do it
grab that super energy off those zorps
i mean the big the big balls big globes
oh he dead he did nice
this is good this is a good activity
this feels good
all right let's see what deserves all
right
hey i got a strange coin i haven't seen
that in a
hot minute
jerry sounds like a [ __ ] magician
right now like he's doing a game show
host spit yeah oh i just got uh arsenic
bite that's not
what that's not very good
old anti extinction mask that is not
very bloggers now oh we're gonna um i
think end up in a better
uh space in a second though the big
treasure vault okay
and that's where the cool stuff is and
that's where you'll spend the strange
coins you can actually spend them with
the option or just like a
vendor oh yeah that's cool they brought
back the strange coins
yeah
been in a while
i have a sweetie sweaty confetti
legendary mod for weapons
that will make guys blow up with
confetti and precision kills oh my god
okay
what is that like a like a school thing
i got out of it yeah i believe so i
think it's going to be like the
children's birthday party halo mod or
halo
halo skull right yeah yeah every time
you shoot a grunt or whatever it's like
explosions happen and like cheers go on
or some [ __ ] yeah i'll apply that for
next time
me
okay
where is it take us
it should take us to the black hole
all right
that thing always looks sick as hell
that good good art direction you know
this is
uh one treasure here get a 30th
anniversary weapon up front here
okay
and then get your quest off zersky the
will of the great star horse
damn
oh yeah and if you take his resplendent
package whatever it gives you a br
okay sick
oh my god look at all this
oh i got that the retraced path
all right wow a lot of stuff let's see
strange key
interesting zer bounties
yep they're bounties horse has bounties
too but you gotta spend strange coins
to get them
and then oh here's the forerunner okay
he's got a weapon ornament for gal horn
oh my god there's a shotgun called
pardon our dust
that's so good
okay yeah yeah okay i see the gallon
quest now too yeah um
the forerunner is the halo pistol
oh okay you need seven strange coins too
uh sir also has the gallahorn quest
yeah yeah i just i just grabbed that
we can all do that together let's go
wait wait wait not yet no i mean like
let's go
[Laughter]
i was like
[Laughter]
i just got here
okay there's the
[Music]
battle rifle
i got about rifle too nice
excellent is there a shader i can do to
to make it look all black
or green
i don't know imagine
okay i had so i had multiple keys
because i ran
the dares already once when i loaded in
right and so you can just like spend
them all at once if you really want to i
got
the battle rifle and i got something
else kinetic uh shotgun wastelander
you can dump them in the other places
too so here's a celebration weapon mod
chest
all these different chests do different
things okay we gotta we gotta increase
our rank though for a lot of these oh
okay these are cosmetics
like here's the ship one yeah
oh [ __ ] and i see okay so the ones that
are probably more rare like this one
costs
seven [ __ ] treasures
strange favorite rank 16 three treasure
keys
sick dude oh [ __ ] okay and it's
class-based huh like i see the warlock
armor sets here and the hunter oh
all right that's nice so you can like
see what you're getting yeah exactly
exactly what you're getting that's
that's right i like that yeah i like
that yeah that is very nice
all right let's see this yeah i got the
part in our dust let's check this out
it is a eternal equine uh
see
with blinding grenades oh yeah yeah you
need like a bunch of strange coins to do
that oh yeah okay
perpetual motions gain stability
handling and reload speed while the
wheeler is in motion are you kidding
yes all right
dope dude let's go
put on my other hat all right
sick so uh
i got that package right i should open
yeah open that package get your beanie
it's the hunter
yeah give me that
whoa what are these new
blinds
sick
um you should have got the sweaty
confetti mod too
oh i do see that
oh
it's like run birthday party
i'm so into it oh my god
so i gotta do
magnum opus quest says i gotta do horse
bounties
the titan set's called ring walker
that's very good
nice
um
yeah i guess let's apply the uh 30th
anniversary junk huh real quick over
here
i'm worried i think some of it might
have gone to the tower for me
it's all it should be all unlocks in
your inventory if you've got the space
okay no i see it
um
oh yeah wow there was a lot in that
yeah it's all three sets
and do we get that because we
bought the 30th annie is that just like
a gift i'm not sure i think i think you
just get it for having the
thing yeah
uh
reversal wow dude a lot of stuff in here
that's a weekly star horse bounty
oh these are all weekly uh okay no three
of them are weekly one of them there we
go
oh i love it
here's why that here's why the um points
matter too yeah it looks good dude
let's see then the different okay so
that one does the
yeah
sick all right
get a picture of that horse
a little more left there we go
okay
is there anything else i think i got an
emote what did i get
yeah there we go
oh weird i can't see it shot for the
gram with the horse
oh i don't know what emote i got
that's uh it might be a blue one it was
called ragdoll ragdoll oh there it is
what
let's check it out
oh is that the one i saw people
yep
there it is oh it's from getting blown
up with a grenadine in halo i saw
someone doing this in the tower and i
was like that's wild looking what's
going on there yeah yeah yeah let's get
it
[Laughter]
man
that's pretty good
uh
can we use some of this hour just super
quick and then we can go to no let's do
it shawhan and duke gallahorn and
dungeon and all that let's do gal horn
oh i have another treasure key
yeah i may as well spend mine too huh oh
wait return is there an eternity
i got two partner dust okay
i am an agent oh yeah he's got some for
me too
play dare earn chess
yeah and you should be able to grab the
magnum opus
quest i think yeah okay yeah yeah i just
got it now okay cool cool
very sick very
cool
more sweaty confetti oh cool i have all
the strange coins now excellent but now
i gotta go do some start okay then let
me go get the bounties
all right we checked all that we were
about to leave steps yeah
oh
uh is it just regular bounties is or is
it
they're for dare
uh some of our daily some are weekly
okay but like does he require me to do
specific ones i just wanna make sure i'm
grabbing the right
i think it's any of them but i think you
can only hold one at a time as you can
and they're costly
oh why did fireworks just go off
uh because i i did a celebration weapon
mark you can only hold one at a time man
okay why would i spend five strange
coins on glimmer that seems ridiculous
yeah uh yeah i think in later when you
have way too much that's pretty yeah
it's probably like hey the activity is
coming to an end
you don't need any strange coins anymore
goku
retraced path is a covenant gun
yeah
yeah it looks like uh it reminds me of
like the carbine
um or that uh oh
you know what actually reminds me of
there is a
uh
sniper rifle
in halo reach that is like a laser
sniper rifle it looks a lot like that
which would make sense because it's a
trace rifle
dude okay so this mod is literally the
grenade melee gunfire
triangle final blows with this weapon
grant bonus damage while this buff is
active
grenade and melee kills of the same
damage type greatly increase its damage
and duration so flip on solar that's
nuts golden tricorn it's called and it's
the bungie logo
someone chad's asking why is uh some of
the parts pixelated this on low graphics
that might be a stream issue uh if
that's the case because it looks totally
fine on my end so yeah it must be uh
don't blame the game blame my stream
blame comcast blame comcast
all right i am all good yeah i'm good
let's let's go
um all right i have to do it
i'm too used to you guys being uh so go
to the tower real quick
uh yeah please
i like wanna fit out the new 38th annie
ornaments but the way that i have my
warlock set up now he just looks so
badass that it's like hard for me to
uh focus rifle is yes that's what people
in the chat uh that is what that weapon
was yeah yeah yeah thank you
that that that feels a hundred percent
like a focus rifle reference uh
also i'm curious to see how it looks but
i did throw um
uh
skele ghoul on the uh battle rifle and
it looks pretty good
as far as getting like an all black
right
so pro tip
maybe go with that that shader if that's
what you're looking for yeah maybe i'll
maybe i'll whip up a guide
[Laughter]
checking checking checking
all right
um i believe i'm square whenever you
guys are ready
yeah
yeah i'm good
how do you throw this confetti on the uh
my gun real quick
yeah
i'm gonna pull out this trace rifle
uh
damn
then i can't use the br though
[Laughter]
all right we'll take turns all right
one at a time
how do you get gallahorn so uh after you
do the um
first dare activity you end up going to
that treasure room which we were just in
and
uh once you talk to azer he's going to
give you uh this quest called uh
uh and out flies the wolves uh and that
is the quest that it will give us gal
horn so
yeah in fact we're about to start
running about to go start it right now
so stay tuned and you'll uh you'll see
how to do it
uh okay you guys all let me know when
you're good
all good yeah just a sec
i've got so much junk up in my brooking
postmaster
yeah i use it as extra vault space which
is bad because then stuff gets deleted
where's skelegool
what season is that from sean luke do
you remember oh um it's one of the uh
anyway
uh
hold on let me check but it's from uh
the festival of the lost
gotcha
uh i think it is
i need some kind of shader search
yeah right um for me it shows up on my
fourth page and yeah it's the festival
the lost icon
okay thank you appreciate it
ah there it is
that's pretty good
yeah not bad
yeah
although i wonder if we'll come across a
30th anniversary shooter like an actual
yeah
game day says there's a legendary trace
rifle now there is they actually have
added legendary trace rifles finally
all right i
am
good okay is chris good i see he's
talking to
or he's in his his uh vault right now oh
wait can four people
go to shaw i'm not sure if we can oh
uh uh
chris we're gonna have to boot chris
he's gonna be like all right should we
tell him or we should yeah give give him
my condolences
my condolences two three four
[Music]
i'm so sorry
chris
my bad
oh it hurts so bad uh okay let's do this
man yeah they should just let you run
around
like the the zones as a group of six by
now
i'm sure there's like a weird technical
limitation for why they can't and i
imagine like doing that breaks a billion
other things but
surely i would like that at some point
it's probably to lester's fault if we're
being honest like
[Laughter]
probably
i saw on reddit the other day somebody
was like mocked up a telesto
look forward to the next uh anniversary
where they do like a telesto themed
dungeon
oh my god
is dim working right now
yeah it is nice
yeah i'm using it right now
good
yeah this is going remarkably smoothly
chris said ripped in the chat i'm so
sorry
talked to you in a whole year
you've been around the system a bit yeah
yeah just got shot you're such an idiot
well he thinks he thinks he's we're the
all right he yeah he ever met yeah yeah
he thinks he's like your mentor he's
like oh my god if we weren't okay we
just gotta go do the dungeon yeah sick
dope let's do it hang on
i want to keep reading it though one
time okay i'm gonna shoot this oh my god
i just realized the uh the icon for the
battle rifle
looks exactly like
uh can you get to the loot cave to check
it out for me any old piece of tech
might help the vanguard oh man
here we go let's get some cosmodrome
uh bounties
oh it takes place in cosmodrome yeah
yeah right good point yeah okay just
grab them might as well yeah weapon
just spend all my glimmer
yeah i know right
okay
square
okay yep
we need to
uh grasp everest
is a marker on the director at the top
is that where we're going or do we have
to actually let me look at that
i think we actually have to go to it um
no it's just oh no i see it i see it
yeah there we go
all right legend uh 1310
nice let's do it
i don't know guys i don't know if we're
high enough
i will say you have to forgive me um
because of the way my setup is something
about like destiny does not like obs uh
or just streaming in general um but it
does cause my game to like
be a little more um
hitchy than usual so
forgive me if i'm
if i'm not on that point
as usual
this is actually a free track you can
get from the bungie store for the gather
days
thing yeah i was listening to it it's a
good pirate theme energy about it
yeah
ah love me a good breach
grenade launcher
uh okay that's an example of all these
nerds whoa look at all the ingredients
dude do not do not touch the eggs do not
touch the end grips you don't touch the
end grips oh you get burdened yeah oh
yeah this is all it's all about greed
don't be greedy oh you're not supposed
to
run into it right away i have a debuff
for like 30 seconds now i'm going to
touch one just to see how it works
are they different i wonder burdened by
riches oh my god
it stacks it stacks up no so so okay so
when my timer ran out oh it almost died
yeah you have to grab them
oh no you have to keep it up yeah and i
have to keep it up it's like a special
set of girls that's even better you have
okay so
succumb to greed you can't stop
succumbing to grief so either don't
touch them or always touch them it's
like it's like a fable
[Laughter]
cool
all right it's fun this is i mean it
seems kind of inevitable that you'll
just
i'm up to 17 i wonder if you blow up
eventually all right
oh i did i i blew up
your temptations leave you okay okay
i see my stacks kind of
lowering a little bit uh it's like doing
weird things to this crystal is the
crystal getting bigger
yeah it's doing something okay so i
think what happens is you gather up the
engrams you bring them to the crystal it
takes them from you and then slowly
opens we have to feed it okay yeah i got
it ah
all right
we do have to pick them up yeah yeah
that makes sense
that's cool i like it
it's a moral and it's a game mechanic
this is gonna be hilarious okay so
uh whoever's in the chat who's not an
old destiny fan and might be interested
in knowing this
back in the very first days of destiny
we
where the leveling in this game was
brutal
it was very hard to to climb especially
once you hit the end game content um
it was before like infusion was the
thing a bunch of other mechanics that
are now part of the game were not in the
game yeah this is literally week one of
the game so we would stand over here
somebody discovered that enemies spawn
infinitely
if you kill them fast enough from this
stupid cave right here so we would all
stand way back here
because you have to be far enough away
from the cave where they won't spawn in
and we would just unload on it we just
like 12 people would just stand there
and shoot into the cave and kill people
as they came streaming out of it
constantly
and would kill so many enemies
that they would actually drop a ton of
engrams
because it was really hard to get world
drops otherwise right
the remains
oh
we're going down yeah yeah
anyway that's what the loot cave was we
would just stand there and instead of
playing the game we'd just stand there
for hours
of the treasure are you talking about
randall the vandal
no
oh maybe
allure
um yeah so anyway we would stand there
for hours shooting into the cave rather
than play the game for real because
that's how bad leveling was
and
and eventually you know like a week
later destiny or uh bungie patched it
because it sucked and then they found
better ways to do
um the level grinds
but
if you go to that cave now there's still
like a little easter egg joke thing
where you can activate an item on the
ground and it will
do like a weird little whisper
about
master rahul's bloodlust or something i
forget what it says exactly but that was
because we would you know we had to
bring all the engrams to rule uh at the
end of it
and
we just were down there forever anyway
so that's the story of the loot cave and
it's like a destiny legend
now the game is much better all the
people in the chat are reminiscing about
the good old yeah
it was never good it was the worst it's
only good it's like a good story it's
you know memory but you was a bad week
[Laughter]
there wasn't anything actually fun about
sitting there it sucked it was the worst
it does i love destiny but i hated
destiny back in the day i was so bummed
like the gun play was always great the
leveling was always terrible but i had
to play for work
and now i really enjoy the game because
they've fixed all those issues
but yeah the loot cave was like
that was the whole thing
but this is excellent the idea that this
is a big joke
based on the history of destiny and like
very arguably the worst thing about the
game okay it looks like whoa what just
happened
y'all got blown up by a trap
what the heck check it out the bridge
popped up oh
oh it's no booby trapped because this is
a treasure hunting
pirate themed look see these other
there's two other doors
and they're say don't go in them this
one says it'll kill you if you go in it
and this one says nothing
so where are you going
i'm up here
i was trying to see if there was
anything up here
so do you think the one that says don't
go in it is actually the right one yeah
oh it must be
[Laughter]
uh spikes kill them
oh man
this is great okay
i'm gonna try the other door real quick
yeah oh [ __ ]
here i think we need to go oh good this
is so good
man
that like you couldn't have scripted
that better it was like oh yeah
god damn it
all right all right did that actually
speed through oh no guys this is the
plate it's the plate on the bottom don't
jump on the plate yeah
we keep bumping into each other and
that's not helping stop going all right
all right all right all right watch i'm
gonna do it i know how to i've seen
indiana jones no i already hit the
button
you don't need to go back in there i
already pressed it
i had to revive david the time around it
is 45 seconds to just mock you oh yeah
like we got to make it as long as
possible oh oh that's another one
oh god
what killed you right there
i don't know
ridiculous
i'm getting like no oxygen in my brain
dude it was just a miracle right now so
you hit the button well it murdered you
uh you'll be interacted with the thingy
and the ceiling just dropped in the
ceiling yeah
yeah
okay
is there anything in the ceiling
potentially no there's a button here
that says deactivate
nope that killed me on the way up
interesting oh
[Laughter]
oh man okay
this whole dungeon is one big troll got
it
[Laughter]
all right
so okay
this one oh [ __ ]
yeah
indiana jones that one yeah
i hit that awesome we're good don't
cross that bridge oh okay yeah don't
cross the bridge but i thought it would
okay that will drop hang on let me just
one of us go and mess with that button
the rest of us can wait see what happens
okay and then it will kill you it's
going to drop from that side the left
side yes yes it's going to drop like
that okay yeah so maybe
[Music]
oh the buttons on this okay
okay i'll go next
maybe that's just part of it it's just
like you got to be a guardian willing to
kill yourself over and over okay to get
to this treasure uh
then the deactivate will make it go up
and it will kill you on the way hold on
i see it over here
oh okay oh
nice trick okay there is a
uh
little like panel with a bunch of looks
like a a map and there's a bunch of
doors and they're all blinking red
oh [ __ ] okay oh damn i'm gonna die
so when the when the bridge
david stand back i'll hit the button
okay can't do it
all right uh i'll be there in 45 okay
i'm going to get some more coffee while
we wait okay they'll turn green they all
turn green what does that mean maybe we
go back now
maybe what do you
yeah
i'm gonna
grab phil
run back to the first room here
yes uh up up come back
okay
no
oh rip man warlock jumps
need me to come grab you
uh if you wanna
i don't know how long that's gonna take
so
all right sorry i'm back
so we figured out the little room that
john luke found we like activated
something okay and it like
and it like removed all of the
it removed all of the red um
it was like red icons
yeah so and now they're all green now
here phil if we go back here if you look
up those uh circular doors are now all
open all right here
so
pick one of those
well if we each take one one of us has
got to survive right
okay
i'll take this furthest away one
what about the ones behind us i don't
know
uh oh here this one oh yeah there are
six in fact this one's a dead and this
one's this one also looks like a dead
end and it has a what looks like a
pressure plate yeah this one has a
pressure plate on it too yep
oh hey that opens
uh my pressure plate open to trap door
oh my god
yeah it
either activates the fan
and shoots you out of there or it opens
the hole and i think i picked the right
one yeah i think you guys david
nice life size we should uh i want to
demonstrate that for the stream though
that was fun oh yeah yeah the fan yeah
luke come look at me while i die
[Laughter]
sure or david david could do it either
way all right well let's go all right
check this out
in a much more brutal way than what you
saw because i i ruined it i ruined
everything laddered him when he came
rifle a legendary that is correct about
a rifle it is a legend there we go oh my
god oh yeah
it's on my menu
oh it's fine
yeah we'll give this up in just a second
but yeah the uh the halo pistol the
magnum that is an exotic
rest of this stuff is legendary
and you get the br first thing basically
all right here we go ready
oh okay you're doing it hold on hold on
hold on okay
[Laughter]
okay
i'm gonna move forward hold on
yeah let's go
uh
was it the middle it's the
left one yeah
like zol
oh i think you're right oh
okay
well immediately get spiked
okay
but that does seem like the path forward
it is
it is it is i just uh where did where
did you get spiked from i'm like very
cautious coming to your order so
when no no you can you can grab my orb
my orbs okay sick um here if you go they
tend not to put you in the trap which is
nice that's nice
right here i just like overshot this
little jump um and then landed right in
those spikes oh okay
really easy to avoid actually another
pressure plate right there yup don't hit
that one
what happens if you do though i don't
well no
i'll step on it i'll revive you yeah
yeah yeah if we want to do it for comedy
oh
okay that's pretty good
and then what this bridge gives out yeah
the bridge gives out
nice nice
this is
okay
oh another one of these cool
all right
oh
the two is
front left and middle are those the uh
things you did before
this one no this looks different this is
a different room
okay so hold on if it's for this one's
red
and the middle one over there was red so
we want the green ones then right
yeah i think so although can i can i
test something can i deactivate it real
quick because i think it changed
baseline
because there's green yeah now the
middle oh okay so look it's true so they
like swap yeah
look these are the red ones take it take
note of which one of the red ones are
because some of them are going to be
green on top of the red
and then the x is like what's inside
right okay yeah yeah yeah
so we want which one
uh
wait
do it one more time
hmm
i think we want all they're all though
i think we want this one wait wait do it
again
yeah one more time oh no now it's no
they're all uh
well hell
well then well which one isn't
all then yeah so this one isn't blinking
at all no matter what same for these two
neither is this one all right here yeah
you guys open this four
i'm gonna go out you can close that i'll
try some you tell me which one to try
okay what did that just do
for you when i uh
actually didn't open the path right in
front of you
the path in front of me is open right
now
okay try i guess going through that one
okay
how do you go through this path
uh there's some thrall in here
okay
and there's another thing i can activate
oh my god there's a lot of people
no don't do the caddies at me okay
uh i just activated another
panel it looks the exact same though
there's no difference to the um
the icons or anything like that
okay yeah no it's the same but i can but
i can open it but i can open it for you
guys oh right
yeah so i think that's i think it's yeah
multi-step here is what we're yeah what
we're learning also i'm dead please come
get me okay oh
all right uh jm says where do you get
gel horn you get gal horn for doing this
dungeon uh which is what we're doing
right now what killed both of you uh the
pressure plate next to me i see it okay
oh [ __ ]
wife just brought me cheetos mac and
cheese
oh dude i bought that
because i was like i gotta know uh but i
haven't tried it yet yeah i gotta know
sometimes did you get the regular or the
flaming this
okay we got the flaming hot one but
we're like we got it but it's been
sitting in our pantry for weeks because
we're like too afraid to actually try it
yeah i'll investigate later on the
stream
when we're closer to lunch yes please
please let me know
so
which room are we in right now it's the
oh it's like
because they're connected yeah yeah
we're on the street across one we
started here
i think again right and then we're
straight across
okay um so we want what do we want the
middle one now the bottom middle one so
straight across in the middle
this one of us has to stay behind and
push the button damn it i did it again
i think i think we keep have to have
people stay behind and push buttons i
think we gotta get a little bit you guys
go i'll stay yeah i'm gonna show you the
bridge here
i want john luke to go no matter what
because he's the one with the video yeah
yeah truth
um can you activate it so i can get out
too you can get out go take the other
door left oh okay
yeah all right where can we get the halo
pistol exotic quest uh you uh get that
from the uh
the star horse
yeah we're we have that one right now
but you you've got to do a bunch of
bounties uh for the other activity
yeah it's the dare activity oh these are
worms
okay i guess i'll just sit quietly so i
think the idea is we're just moving like
a little bit at the time until we get to
somewhere
yeah
uh pressure played right there the
thrall just stepped on it thank you
i wish it killed them
it did oh it did excellent yeah good to
know okay
all right we've activated one on here
i heard a button i heard a thing happen
okay i can leave so what should i leave
frog ah damn it
okay hold on david you stay here for a
sec i'm gonna investigate dude i keep i
keep hitting that same
pressure plate
like four in a row
uh
okay this
30 more seconds
i found it
nice
that sounds like something happened yep
that was a different trick
big streaker outside
oh nice okay uh we have to go back now
all right so you can come to me
i'll be back in 10 seconds
oh my god
you saw that
that did it
uh
all right here let me activate that oh
yeah i need to activate it
okay
all right we should be good
oh i'm back at the beginning
that's actually good
okay that's actually the way we need to
go
oh really we're coming back yeah yeah uh
the door next to the bridge opened
can i activate this and come help you
guys uh yes please do all right
oh yeah up here we opened up here oh
great
i keep being dead for like all the
puzzle solving okay and then
now we've opened the other side
ah
okay
so this was like the master switch
basically oh the bridges are gone
yeah i think we still have to
leapfrog a little bit here
uh i made a mistake
oh oh [ __ ] i fell off i just saw that oh
all right let me grab you guys
okay so uh
we'll we'll just we just have to go back
through the rooms and and do what we did
before
okay okay
so yeah here we'll go back in here you
activate that one david get up that yes
which yeah
i don't want you to get killed
okay
guys
uh let me
oh you can come out nice uh yeah i think
you make it to this one yep
everyone get over here more thralls oh
it's dark in here
yes i don't think you needed to stay
uh
necessarily to move forward although i
guess because you're going back and
forth if you if you wanted to do it
really fast you could kind of have
people sit in certain spots and have one
person go
watch out for this pressure plate in the
middle here yeah
yeah it's it's but these rooms have two
entrances and exits that's cool
i'm gonna check the other one real quick
just to see what was there
oh that that's where i went um to
activate it yeah yeah
that's that's how i activated the big
door
there are two doors here
um
yeah well who wants to guinea pig it
okay all right i'm on it all right
oh that one was spikes not that one
thank you for your sacrifice
nice okay
okay
there's like nine lore things in here
too where i have to come back and look
for them oh sure
yeah i bet we've already missed a couple
yeah absolutely i think we might have
missed one at the front door to be
honest
uh
guys i need help i got the anniversary
pack but i didn't get the casual set
which is set to unlock instantly can
someone tell me how to get them so after
you do the first dare you go to the
treasure room talk to zur he's gonna
give you a uh anniversary pack uh boxes
like gold box go to your inventory
uh and then like hit it to open it that
will give you all the casual stuff
yeah all three characters and you get it
for all three for all three classes so
you just you have everything from the
guy yeah it's like it's like a box
inside a boat box and then you have to
unlock all the things too yes
but that's how you do the process
i've got a uh there's a little thing
right here it's got one two three four
labeled on it and i see the numbers for
each door so we're at
we're at one right now four's over there
you're probably on three phil yeah i'm
at three so yeah so yeah
okay go ahead oh hey chest i found a
chest hang on time time on time
i found a secret of some kind
i don't know if i can get to that is it
a real chest it's a it's a chest chest
like it's a great chest looking chest
you know you see it up there
where right there oh there it is hold on
maybe i can get it yep
nice
oh very nice it just gave me glimmer
i didn't get anything damn it
season ring progress
maybe it's a 800 glimmer oh yeah maybe
that's a triumph for like finding these
or something
oh we did find the first message that's
good
okay uh david go ahead and hit that
button
yeah yeah so right now so all three
doors are locked except for number four
if i activate it
uh three opens up one and two stay
locked three is open uh and there are
enemies in here
oh it kind of the doors kind of like got
broken
okay
see how they like they like started
opening and they started to fail yeah
yeah yeah
that makes me concerned they're gonna
yeah i have a feeling we're gonna get
squashed to be honest
but i see another control panel inside
i'm going to switch over to the
uh that trace rifle yeah let's see how
that thing works all right i'll activate
it it looks sick uh one just opened up
dude this is a hundred percent the focus
rifle from halo reach
i feel like this one they can get away
with because that gun was only ever in
halo reach they've never put in any
other halo game so i think bungie's a
little more like yeah we could do it uh
there is nobody
in here
what there is another thing in here um
like similar to yours david but i can't
press it uh oh i already pressed it you
already pressed it got it yeah so one
just opened up and now i'm i'm in here
uh
i say i see and then and then two
i guess we'll open up because that's the
last one
nice yep
all right so the doors break so that you
don't get locked in that's nice of it
got it okay so where are we going now
uh number two
yeah this guy's sick nice
yeah there's there's no like
nerf licensing deal
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah like microsoft lawyers are like uh
the halo battle rifle is
uh proprietary that one that one we
definitely have a nerf gun
so you can't have it
uh okay so you got a scorch cannon that
must be the trick to this because yeah
it's marked on my hud like it's oh yeah
like it's a thing
oh really okay okay
shoot the shoot that thing at four oh
yeah yeah
oh maybe just take it over there
oh maybe i shoot it in because i see a
little yeah shoot it inside it
what do you think is that gonna explode
maybe just stop
oh yeah it works nice
oh
hello
okay
well i mean there was also like a hive
wall thing right yeah
yeah shoot it again we'll try and slide
in
okay then shoot up maybe shoot it lots
sheet of wood several times
yeah i did it
nice oh no
[Laughter]
on the side of the wall here why because
why is there a little two by two
spot where you could just slip into the
oh okay
oh do we have to do all that again
oh
devious
all right that that won't take that long
yeah now we know how to do it now that
we know what to do
all activate
that's hilarious
it's like resident evil 4 flaming barrel
[ __ ]
that will help guy what a jerk
yeah willem's a bastard dude
[Laughter]
uh
luke do you need a hand over there no i
got it all right activated
how did it too okay i know it's one next
yeah it's one i'm here
i'll head over to two oh
damn all right two should be open now
yeah
mm-hmm
there's a shot cannon guy
very short scorch rather
all right
okay
and now we head over to what was it for
yeah
i'm excited for a cosmodrome dungeon i
hadn't mentioned this before but like
i know we spent a lot of time in the
cosmodrome in destiny 1 i got real tired
of it now it's back sure
it has cool things about it lately nope
oh i couldn't go in i'd do it twice i
guess
nope uh i think so
no no no no
stop stop stop oh okay yeah yeah
sorry
because because i had held down
all right
somebody said well there it is i did it
nice
um there's probably more than one
i was able to get all the way up
okay bring that up like another two more
shots oh okay i will i will grab
it more shots
oh these stairs are weird who knows man
there could be like a secret chest you
get if you uh don't waste anything
yeah so i was like panicking because if
you hold down the uh the trigger it'll
you can just like okay there is a door
over here but there is a pressure plate
on it uh there's a little cubby here
that you can like crawl into
up top oh yeah okay that looks like the
trick
let's go get killed by that door real
quick though just for
science science
i don't see anything over here
i hear weird noises you hear that
your spooky sounds
hey
what's over there
uh oh another cubby
with oh something to collect
nice is it lore i think so
right all right hop over the yep okay
yeah
nice look it's like a message in a
bottle nice
oh man
that's good
[Laughter]
this guy is a psycho for the loot
um
so that was like message number six
oh yeah we died so we missed
i'm gonna try jumping over to that door
yeah
pressure plate oh this is cool i like
that no i don't see any
sick
all right seems to be safe
although i don't really know where to go
from here
yeah
um
uh oh if you look over time to the right
you see that it says hello
yeah it's very dark on mine super dark
on my screen though
uh oh i did see something i don't know
if it um
let me try it again better from over
here almost
right there yeah yeah i see what you're
shooting now
your ghost is over there now oh [ __ ]
well that sucks well i mean that
indicates to me that that's the right
way to go
possibly yeah i see i see some more um
it's tricky but it's you can do it yeah
there's like there's like little frames
you see them like right there yeah it's
very dark oh yeah it's just so dark i
can't see i'm gonna have to turn up my
brightness real quick
tricky
do you have to have three people to do
this dungeon uh
that's a good question um i mean i'm
sure you can solo it right you probably
can solo it um
but i think you guys can just jump
really from from there to
yeah from where phil was okay let me try
that although i'm not sure if this was
like a warlock privilege for me to make
this yeah i'm a little i think i can do
it
no i can't
drive my zombies i do have my stoppies
i'll just throw those on
okay i have to call mine out but i can
do that too
yeah
you know what it might be too because
like we were
showing like were we over there
uh yes
okay yeah cause maybe you just jump
around onto that platform and that gives
you the light oh
the little edge you need you know yeah
you know what that's a good point that
might have been a little extra oh you
just
you do that what a longer jump you think
yeah like like because we started here
and we were looking yeah you just like
do a running start or something and then
oh except
i don't know that seems to be far away
to me
i i could have made that i just like
didn't do my double jump at all
for a hundred it seems a little far
maybe not maybe you're right okay
you wore locks in your levitation
a little graceful float
make sure you look for lore
oh
hey we're on the other side of uh isn't
this sepik's arena
it is
okay
the other side of that bridge that's
cool rally banner right here oh that's
rad
let's switch it back to that battle
rifle that's that's dope
sick let's go over there
all right
frisia the insatiable oh man
he's immune
okay
uh being burdened does not
do anything as far as damaging him goes
so it's for something else
to like maybe charge like how we do that
crystal or something probably
yeah so i guess i'm sorry i apologize
for dying immediately it's okay i'm
about to die from being burdened
you get gal horn from the dungeon or
from a different quest from the dungeon
you have to uh have the quest uh from so
yeah
the quest took us to the dungeon and
then the quest tells you to go to the
dungeon but it's a pretty
straightforward like there's no other
steps to it it's like you get the quest
you go talk to uh sean han you go to the
dungeon
everest crystal is down here that they
gonna bring the burden to yeah yeah so
we started okay also there is a scorch
cannon oh my god thralls get off me
there
sorry where's that crystal
right here right here oh
what is this scorch cannon used for you
think maybe just add clear or something
more no i think it's another puzzle
thing because it's got another hot icon
like last time okay
it could be to to
damage him
yeah
i shot him and it was immune so let me
try again um well okay so here the weird
thing is that uh there is no
can you shoot the crystal
oh
over here question oh wait no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no over here
yeah
it is not that one it's the other one in
the same spot across
because the other one is close see over
here okay yeah nice
they don't do anything what
that's still
the walls are still kind of immune yeah
i can't get in there
uh yeah keep doing it keep charging it
it took several charges last time yep
that did it
doors open
yep okay come in there we go
what oh okay
you trust me
okay here we go more engrams get all
that stuff
and then go
[Music]
so yeah i'm gonna shoot stephen crystal
and we go yeah
if you um stay near the crystal too i
think it just siphons it from you yeah i
believe so
i don't know if you have to shoot it or
yeah if it's just a cycling thing
yeah
oh he's doing that though
this is damageable no it's still immune
yeah the crystal's not big enough i
don't think okay
uh take that scorch cannon and try the
do the other side now yeah yeah uh that
is the last one
okay i need another scorch cannon
okay well that that's probably why the
ads are coming now because it came from
a vandal so just look for a vandal with
the
scorch and we'll just pop oh my gosh oh
yeah here he is he's on me
there is nowhere to hide from him
okay i got the scorch cannon nice
okay
there we go
looks like you have to do it three times
probably
make sure you're picking up all these
engrams
okay
dope dope
okay that's that
oh my god it would be
nice if this dude could just not shoot
me okay i'm depositing my riches now oh
gotcha there we go that might be enough
oh we can damage him
yeah there we go
i'm gonna hit him with a short scorch
cannon i guess
oh he's got a lot of health
this thing does not seem like it's worth
the effort i'm gonna throw it away wow
oh [ __ ] he's on the move
all right again and we rinse and repeat
i'm gonna swap to some boss weapons
yeah
i need uh
i need a lot better dps than that so
i'm opening the first door
okay let me pull out my reads regret
it's unstoppable on what is that
arms
okay yeah one full scorch cannon will
pop open the thing
fyi
oh you guys are dead
oh sorry i'm totally applying my armor
uh i'm afraid i will get killed trying
to come save you
okay
i just brought up all the ads
by opening that door oh good you can
wait
uh isn't this the sepex area it is it is
which is pretty cool we came in from the
other side of that that broken bridge
i think i can open both doors right now
probably
although we should probably just wait
uh so we don't lose out on
the engrams
well
don't kill them
because i already did it so
oh no they close that for a minute okay
okay which one do we go for
uh the the one to your left
well i need mother and graham
okay i gotta go deposit real quick
no no no no don't die don't die oh my
god damn it i died
oh that sucks
i got you i got you i got you
yeah
it's more than i lost all my
stuff to deposit
oh yeah yeah no i'm just saying wither i
was just commenting on a good idea for
gear
yeah i got mine in
i don't know what happened in the scorch
game i think it's going
yeah there's another one over here
it's an intense fight oh no
okay i got the scorch cannon oh my god
stop shooting me yeah come down here
if you hold okay i'll do it yeah got it
oh my god
okay is that all of them
uh i think so all right cool
not quite enough
yeah
it's because i died that's all right
i should put particle on huh
whoops that's what i did
yeah
ugh
okay
all right
oh yeah
oh damn
okay
is that all of them
i think so except for the guys we were
outside
there we go nice
mess them up
significantly better yeah yeah
okay
i'm having a hard
yeah
you just picked up an engram baby be
careful
they love shattered
handle ended up somewhere weird
okay opening the first door could be the
left side one
if you just shoot it immediately three
times it'll open
charge up about halfway we'll also do it
right
gtfo okay
all right popping the other door whoops
oh i could use more heavy
yeah a little light too
maybe i switched to uh
i think we got them all
nice there it is oh nice
[Music]
he's very close
yeah yeah
he's just doing a thing
oh my heavy
oh come on we're so close
one more yes
nice job
all right let's keep going for 64. i got
a bomb i got
matador 64. be the bull
matador
oh god dude
here we go
yeah the return of the [ __ ] matador
they take away my astral they give me
something even better
dude i mean seriously prepare for people
to start complaining about shotguns
again
everyone was like we want fellow winters
back and everyone's like [ __ ] fellow
winters matadors exactly the door is no
different like
okay
we're not done where do we go now yeah
uh let's probably push through
reverse like reverse devils layer this
or right that's what i'm guessing these
doors it looks like these doors over
here at the front are open
oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah reverse devil's lair yeah
cool
sick for lure look for lure
oh i found one inside this inside this
like drum here because
oh nice
oh yeah
and bismarck
he says we should leave
says there's a curse
says this place is changing me
i know he wants to come back later with
some darks
uh switches here
i'll hit this one it'll probably launch
you yep
[Laughter]
i love that
all right i'll do this one then see
nice oh
okay
oh oh wow oh my god colony ship
nice
okay this is this is nice get on your
sparrow
i was a little a little nervous oh
what happened
uh did we not do whatever we had to do
fast enough mine exploded yeah maybe the
mine exploded i think you gotta get your
sparrow and book it
dude i was like i mean i it was cool for
the devil's lair thing but i was like
worried i'm like are we just going
through the control zones and stuff yeah
and then seeing this it's like oh let's
go so
oh yeah 10 seconds on this thing i saw a
little
ground
okay do we want to wipe and try that we
have to see yeah
oh wow you only just made it yeah let's
get killed
uh what am i doing what's up okay so
remember in uh in
scratch there were the little markers
when this in the sparrow part the little
lights like
a secret chest oh my god really they're
doing that again
yeah yeah actually maybe we could
backtrack and get him after we defuse
the mine because it's pretty intense
there's i bet there's three yeah i
literally like
booked it and just barely made it so i
don't even know yeah dude i saw maybe so
if you guys want to book it i can like
try and stay back and see okay i'll i'll
book it there
um although i definitely need another
person just to help me out yeah it may
be that yeah i'll come with you too it
may be that the idea is to try and hit
all three of them in one go because
they're spread out like here's the right
one i'll get the right one there's one
on the left
i don't know where the middle one it
extends the time of the the mine that's
what it does okay so yeah there's no
okay
okay hello to the mine
well damn you don't even need that then
you could just book it if you want
if you want to live dangerously because
you were on like zero yeah it was really
damn close oh [ __ ] i excellent oh we got
to keep going
oh yeah
oh that is far okay you definitely need
to hit the okay
the mind extenders
come on
yes
feels very make sure i have the [ __ ]
the scourge sparrow so people don't
shoot me as well yeah that's that's a
good idea too
let me get mine oh i actually don't have
mine on me
let me use the let me use the rest real
quick i'll be right back you got it like
30 seconds
that's fine uh what season was that in
geez
uh
whatever the name of the scourge season
was
season six
yeah i think so
maybe
i don't see it though maybe season five
yeah season five they're always on time
right
yep
there we go
yes definitely need less aggro on me
i'm gonna pull out this retraced path
for a bit
although now i have no ammo
so yeah basically as soon as that thing
is diffused we gotta roll mm-hmm
i'm gonna check slack real quick since i
have a bunch of notifications
oh i'm sure
all right how's everyone in the chat
doing
[Music]
[Music]
yeah i should tell david he needs to
meet his mic
[Laughter]
what up david
was that your mom how's your mom
return
dude she's uh she's talking about she's
talking about uh blood pressure right
now uh i gotcha
that's her that's my aunt my aunt just
turned like 85 dude
yeah
hold the [ __ ] good for her
so they're talking about [ __ ] blood
pressure as 85 year olds are
want to do
[Laughter]
all right
all right let's go
message said not mute your mic come on
bro
oh yeah hit the button
all right
i'm gonna take the left
i got the right oh i hit the wall okay i
clicked it
okay way better with the sparrow holy
[ __ ]
yeah
so while you oh it's definitely use the
mind oh it does okay so it's almost
instant it's not exact also
i hit everything oh my god yeah
keep going
yep okay so you can drive over them
basically you're not supposed to yeah
yeah yeah
i just saw it
me too dude i didn't hit it i'm just
trying to beeline it i'm so close nice
okay oh there's one right in that
doorway
that you just nailed i'm behind you
though
okay keep going oh [ __ ]
uh this is fun and cool
this is a cool area okay so there's one
on the right here jean-luc if you oh i
i'm hella dead
yeah
no
i'm just watching
david
that's tough dude
okay
so there's one in that little door that
david went through there was one to the
right just before that and there's one
to the right after it as well so
i think we could find we don't need more
than like one or two
yeah as we keep going i think we're
going to i'm sorry
this is so my bad dude that's 100.
there might be one up at the right there
too
around the back side of that ship
nice hell yeah
okay
i won't die this time
okay i see one on the left i'm grabbing
it
okay i'm at b
this music is i'm gonna get this one at
the right beautiful
hell yeah good [ __ ]
clear
all right get this one on the right af
right after c up that ramp all right
i can grab it i can grab it get it i'm
on fire very slow oh my god
i just grabbed it oh i got shot i'm
gonna make it if i don't blow up i'll
make it oh no
he landed
the timing of that was really good
excellent
we got this though yeah
well we got this to d anyway we'll see
what's after that
let me know when you guys are
i'm immediately going to the right so we
don't bump into each other okay
all right three two one
all right that's the right side one i'm
actually going to take the right path
over here that i've never heard
oh yes this is screwy i went right past
a okay
[ __ ] sorry oh you're okay i missed that
one on the right
and the one on the left i'm missing all
we should we should be okay we should be
okay
here i'll hit it
i got this one
nice
freaking tank
oh we're on top of each other
sorry
ah
oh sorry
you're fine you're fine all right
i'll get the one after c
nevermind you got it i got it you got
the one on the ramp okay yep
i'm going to take the left piston
because that actually will launch you to
uh another mine diffuser nice take the
right one oh oh damn i'm stuck no sorry
no that's my fault i got stuck okay that
time i survived it
oh it launched me right over it okay
that's fine
i don't know where to go from here
i think we did it oh yeah we're done
cool hell yeah
that music is [ __ ] dope dude yeah
that was actually amazing
look at this cool skull cave
yeah oh it is a skull is it yeah
oh
what
ah that's great i love that
pirates man
you think there's some lore like in its
nose or something almost definitely
nose lore
[Laughter]
i can't jump any higher
won't let me
yeah a freaking warlock like david god
yeah oh there's a chest
oh
it might be just like a glimmer chest
again but yeah they
yeah get it uh maybe you can come up
through here like from where i'm right
now maybe that's your way yeah i think
this is the trick over here oh is it
well i might be able to
i might be able to do it the way david
did
i don't know exactly actually here david
where'd you go
uh i am so i went through the nose but
the other way oh okay
i made it along the edge there
i think if you go through the nose
to the right
okay
um
yeah so you go to the right and then
yep just kind of help here and i'm right
here
perfect hey what's is that a a path over
there oh i was getting yeah i was gonna
point that out after i don't know nice
oh
what did you get uh i got a map
oh these are repeatable chests yeah
they're right there
okay i also got enhancement prisms off
that one
oh no really damn think yeah
oh so yeah that's cool there's a little
there's another yeah so that was the
mind thing but it shot me right over
here which is [ __ ] up so i think
okay so though i don't think i can hit
those david maybe you can get to them
but i don't think i can make that jump i
might be able to with stompies i'm gonna
give it a try
yeah yeah
oh
oh oh i did
oh damn all right here we go
nice so i think it brings this
i don't know if i can just take that one
though
yeah it's far does it take us back is
that what it is yeah we're going back to
the other side there must be something
over there then
um
warlock privileges
[Laughter]
um
it didn't make us wait so there's that
i see
okay what about
this
do you see that down there
uh
is that it didn't it took a long time to
kill us i wonder if we can have one if
you can go down there oh maybe
i'm gonna try it
was there anything over there david
what
i got
pushed from the piston like two feet
forward that was [ __ ] up you gotta be
in your car probably
on your bike
oh maybe yeah let me try that again
oh no
it's ludicrous that you could make that
jump oh my god oh so there's nothing in
there david
i i couldn't see anything now okay okay
weird i'm sure mine is extended full
yeah there's gotta be it's just like
yeah i mean maybe
i don't know
it might just be why they wouldn't do
that or put that in there
otherwise
uh yeah let's keep going for now to mess
with me in particular i feel like we can
always uh investigate that later yeah
that really is like
targeted at you
all right
that was that's that's nice i like that
a lot i'm into this
this is a very good dungeon
i'll if it's particularly hard dungeon
but it's just very fun
yeah
you know they don't all have to be hard
no and you know i don't think
we didn't have any trouble with prophecy
did we
uh the first time oh yeah
pit of heresy is probably the
pit might be the hardest yeah pit's
definitely the hardest this is
definitely the hardest prophecy beat our
asses the first couple times remember
well because the light first boss yeah
that was just a light issue very
encounter heavy
yeah
oh what is this jam right now
is this like halo music
i mean it all kind of feels like halo
music
also this area is really cool this whole
thing
falls oh we got another scorch boy here
i'm going to throw down a rally banner
and i'm going to look around
for a sec okay i see a a scorch thing
here that we could oh it activates the
the launchy piston thing so i'll just
leave the square what is this or
whenever we're ready hot air balloon
it's like it's off to see the wizard
[ __ ] i think go in there
all right we activating the piston
uh hang on i
let's investigate the whole area real
fallen
quick
yeah i think i think the shield is the
thing underneath the the hot air balloon
and we have to get in yeah i think so
too
okay all right i'm gonna actually do it
i don't see anything else around so yeah
let's do it
oh wait we can rotate the cannon oh we
can because we got to go to each of
these spots yeah probably
all right
oh
really didn't we didn't quite make it
which is
interesting i i just i did a really bad
jump i like bounced off the [ __ ] edge
absolutely rookie also i love how we
just instinctively put on the new
emblems
of course
okay it's like obligatory right it's
like oh sick
all right do we want to keep trying that
one again do we want to rotate it
i think we need to go to each of these
little settlements
first yeah so i'm down to try it as is
for now okay
all right let's go
all right do it
well it didn't activate for me wow
i think charge it up more yeah you gotta
you gotta shoot three times
okay
i wonder if you could charge you could
just shoot three right now
that'll do it too
okay
it still didn't send me all right let me
do the three times maybe
only one of us can go to time one two
three
nothing yeah
nothing oh that's weird
why did it work the first time
yeah what
i don't know
oh you just stand there you just stand
there you don't jump into it did it work
oh
okay yeah yeah yeah feels right you just
have to stand you should get sucked into
it if you jump into it it messes it up
it kind of like is oh
i see i see i see okay so we got another
crystal thing here inside this this
house
yeah i gotta activate the turkey myself
but i'll join you guys in just a
sec okay yeah another crystal like you
said
and here's another launcher
a little enemy
enemy entrance over there
wow there's a bunch of these there's
like eight different spots with
launchers
and crystals there's a crystal across
the water from us too
you see it in there
well [ __ ] okay all right i'm here well
there's nothing over here so maybe we
just gotta go find the one that is
currently active
yeah i guess so okay all right dredge up
this cannon let's go
okay
all right guys
okay
oh yeah that right away did it oh okay
that hit us into this
nice all right i'm gonna go to the i can
float to this one here i'll see if it's
active
i just went straight to death yeah let's
just say rotate it and i'll launch you
again okay now it's set okay ready
okay just the one guy here though okay
i'm gonna join phil
nope man i might be able to
wow this guy's wrecking me at this
scorch cannon
yeah there's nothing on this island
either uh that i'm on
i guess we'll let's keep going toward
the back
oh
okay so this turret here launches
straight up into the balloon but the
balloon is shielded yes right yeah okay
well if you can come to mine i think
it'll send us over there by that uh skip
part
okay
let's see if i can
well actually let me just rotate this
cannon
there we go
i think what it is is you got to figure
out the correct path instead of going to
all these because they're kind of always
you know
yeah right yeah i agree i mean
it's weird that they
they make it so that like you have to
just stand there as opposed to jumping
through it because that is instinctively
the thing you would do
yeah yeah through these cannons they're
a little finicky oh [ __ ] nobody's up
there i'm charging mine
uh if there's no enemies are there
switches
maybe
maybe yeah that's what i think i i think
we have to get up to
the top and yeah it will happen all
right island that i'm on has a set of
crystals
but no enemies so anyway
um
yeah they all have they're all crystals
on these too it's possible that crystals
are
uh related to like a second phase
yeah and yeah that's true
not fast enough damn dude yeah it's
tricky
there we go
you can shoot it from underneath the
thing so that's good
welcome welcome
that sucked
are there any we haven't visited yet
what's up here what's inside this thing
uh we haven't visited the ones like the
perimeter there's a lure inside that big
turbine i just oh yeah
you're aware
inside this big thing i'm about to jump
into
oh
this guy
very nice
ghosts
did you guys go all the way up to that
big one uh
i have not yet
okay
still working on it yeah we probably try
that one out i'm still trying to get the
lure thing actually this might be a case
of hunter privilege yeah that's nothing
there we go
okay
another crystal
where'd you guys launch yourselves from
oh this one here okay yeah
hmm
man really nothing
we maybe we missed a button where you're
supposed to push
because this is getting weird
fire
it says fire servitor remains at the
fallen shield
are there
okay
i haven't seen any servitor remains have
you oh yeah right there
uh it's called an abundance monitor
yep let's go that way take this launcher
where's the charge thing
there we go
all right
now we're getting all right you bastard
here we go
all right we got some greed in grims
yeah okay he's heck of the mune
yeah
i think we're gonna have to do each of
these islands one at a time
getting toasted
this gun does work
okay oh don't die oh boy that all the
engrams not quite
yes trace is fun
oh that was a scorch candy guy
okay
anymore
that's charged oh okay he's
he we can kill him
and he's dead
okay
oh he's got a timer
what do we do with him oh get him to the
thing roll into the thing we gotta
launch him we gotta launch him huh okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah roll him to the
thing oh no no no no no no no no
he fell off
wait man it's still good
wait hold on hold on it's still good
it's still good it's still good and you
like oh you can go down there okay um oh
there's another surfer right there okay
uh uh if you can get him over there yeah
we got time we got time
oh [ __ ] david careful david careful
david
uh i try okay it's too heavy one at a
time one at a time yeah okay
anyway we're here
dang it okay well
that's annoying
oh my god stop killing me dregs damn it
i lost all my engrams
did david lose connection we lose him no
i'm i'm just i was just waiting for uh a
timer
all right
you guys can hear me right yeah okay
now i was just waiting for the death
countdown
thank you
all right
okay it spawned me way off so i'm gonna
try and catch up with y'all all right
okay
i got accidentally turned on a streaming
thing
come on
dang it
is the new content live right now yes it
is and we're playing it we're doing the
dungeon
okay i'm sorry okay
for a second
no you're good you're good
all right i'll tap out for a sec
so the question is are we do we have to
shoot it at like from the bottom or
whatever directly into it or
any no no no no no so see there's uh
if you look on the sides of it there are
these uh like gold little like thing
yeah
with the with the bar in the middle you
have to launch it with those
ah all right all right yeah they're like
locks
gotcha
yeah
okay
that's it crystal's charged okay
all right so we're gonna kill him right
next to the thing
yeah yeah yeah he's right in position
okay okay
only one of us push it you do it i'll
get the scorch cannon all right we're
set
okay uh yeah let me okay it's rolling
it's good
all right do it yeah yeah
blammo there we
go fantastic
all right uh let's go back to the uh one
above us that thing respawned
yeah cool
nice people that just jumped there do we
have to cannon ourselves
can we counter ourselves
we might be able to
i'm gonna look around for laura for a
minute
yeah we can count on ourselves
okay cool
uh
oh here we go this is i'm really
enjoying how inventive this dungeon is
me too
um is there another scorch
yeah here we go
sorry we're screwing around
back
nice
a lot of enemies around
okay
okay here we go more hats
one of those engrams like fell back into
the spawn point
there we go
all right i'm gonna catch these
i think that might be enough yep
excellent
yeah push let's go oh that that happened
fast okay oh [ __ ] it's rolling badly
uh okay okay
i got a
cannon okay it'll kind of don't don't
lose it to the left yeah okay
it's good
later
nice
nice job
okay let's see where the next one is
oh shoot i'm burned by riches oh no hold
on run run over to the crystal you
we
just came from there right so let me
oh these cannons only rotate two way oh
no nevermind no they rotate three ways
okay sick
all right
over there
to our oh yeah
you're right
sick
oh no
each other and i didn't make it
[Laughter]
i'm dead
where i put my ghost back where we were
yeah
all right i'll be back in 30 seconds
yeah
all right
i just well avarice
no idea
a v a r i c e
i'm tweeting while i'm dead okay
okay got it all right i'm back
the icon of excess is filled with ridges
all right
i'm gonna push it
over okay
i'm trying to get back to you guys i
just can't yet
also remind me to give her some engrams
nice
okay
this guy come on
all right now we're going to go here
all right one sec
so i don't see him there yet but
oh i see him
they're way down there
oh gotcha
we'll we'll we'll take the road yeah
we'll just rotate through
shoot i don't have a scorch cannon
scorch cannon please
damn it
okay
i'm finally gonna catch up
okay
we're just making our way to the next
one
yeah i see you guys
oh no i was not paying attention
not dang really okay
hey i'm with you now ah sick
which thing okay
charging okay
here we go
all right
oh my god stop giving me engrams game
i got so many umbres all right ready
all right
hey here we are
duke
i pulled that vr back out i think it's
too good
yeah so far all my uh
my cool new weapons are on the energy
slot and i'm like i want to use them all
though i know right it's frustrating
nice
okay i'm going to push it
i'll get a scorch cannon
all right let me rotate it for you
okay all set
smart
okay
where's the thing
right here
oh yeah
nice
that's all right
we got all right let's go
uh same place hang on come stand under
the actually let's go one at a time last
time i got killed for it
oh chest over here
hey i got this oh
same
i got oh i got a new piece of armor the
twisting echo vest oh this sword looks
tight
yeah hold on uh wait is this
this isn't the thorn stuff what's this
this is a sword i love it it's so dumb
yes dude look at it look at this thing
this is a freaking sword
dope yeah i got a new chest armor that i
had not seen before ah this game is so
dumb i love it
all right this is like yeah this is this
is a really nice looking sword this is
all over it is that oh yep that's just
gonna shoot us straight up got it come
on up okay let's do it
let's go
uh here you guys go first then i'll go
oh never mind
bounced me off again damn it
barely made it oh that was brutal
is your timer still like 30 seconds yeah
it's at 40.
i'll grab you
yeah don't go all three at once that's
the lesson
hello
oh man there we go
sick as hell
what's a cross here
anything hidden under this anything over
here
no
what sides
or lower tab
oh look at all this gold on the ground
okay nothing in this room
sunken layer
well this is weird i'm like running
vertically up so is this a chunk of a
colony ship yeah dude this room looks
cool
this looks like callus meets the
cosmodrome yeah
this is wilhelm are you sir i hope
wilhelm is there you guys
this has to be the the final room
oh man yeah it's it's got that quality
to it oh this is a turn back spot don't
come up here
okay
uh i can get on top of the door though
i see one green engram there maybe that
triggers it
yeah because it doesn't look like it's
expiring uh
over here
oh yeah let me put my pv wow you could
climb pretty high oh no never mind
i'm looking for
crystals in the middle
there's gotta be lauren here right
probably
probably somewhere
do you die fall in that water i bet
that looks like it
yeah
okay
okay
are we uh
yeah let me circle back to the middle
ready to do this
i mean let me swap to a well
good idea
i guess like a golden gun i didn't even
really thought about playing well
be honest
do i do shotgun or
yeah one sec while i get my nighthawk
oh i also
see up there
a
thing to shoot another scorch cannon
oh okay
oh yeah and there's one on the second
ring too over here
so it's like maybe you create like a
like a a little vacuum tunnel you know
where you like launch something through
it because there's yeah so the first
gate it's the one on top second gate's
on the left
and i don't see where the third one uh
is probably on the right side
yeah i think it's on the right yep it's
on the right
okay
but it's uh it's also in the middle one
oh yeah yeah middle one has two
oh yeah straight above us
oh here we go
enemies are dropping in
are they dropping engrams or no
no no
not at the moment
he's immune though and he's throwing a
mind at us or something yeah
uh scorch cannon
i'm gonna try
that that dude throws the mines that
vandals usually drop oh um shooting that
moved this thing behind you
when you shot it this like launched up
oh
interesting so maybe maybe here let me
stand on it and you can shoot it again
uh
it doesn't seem to be doing anything
anymore
oops
[ __ ] hang on maybe you just have to do
it
i'm getting a little toasted over here i
might die
yeah these drugs are
not messing around okay
oh my exploded on my face
i'm dead
that was annoying
oh yeah yeah i see all these things are
moving you're right
yeah which is maybe
so the the shank above him is
vulnerable but not taking we might just
be setting something up if that's the
case yeah i'm gonna do the third one
yeah i don't think i can write it keep
yeah oh you have to keep right raising
it it stopped and then it fell back down
oh
so it's like the doors where they're not
in place until you charge it a certain
amount okay
i need a new scorch cannon
there's a very tanky shank next to the
boss yeah dude he's got like a little
ghost friend
i'm just getting killed
okay you started to move that one keep
going
i didn't
i made like a noise
it didn't lock into place or anything
yeah
i thought it would lock to be honest
oh okay oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
anchorage
yeah opens up a thing and a bunch of
engrams come out okay
um where do i take these i didn't see
the middle
the crystals in the middle oh i see it
oh i'm getting wrecked though by the
shank
and the boss
that's tough
i'm dead square in the middle like a
fool
thank you good grenade all right let's
roll let's get out of here
oh no all right hang on let's get back
to jean-luc
i'm about to respawn myself okay good
i'm good
um i deposited i think like eight or so
in grams before i died i got five or so
maybe nice okay okay cool all right
i think we just gotta do that again
yep yeah
all right which one are you gonna do
uh this one over here
oh yeah oh he shot him jesus i am just
dying
yeah they're tough
they hit hard all these guys
oh there's a okay so now there's an
invisible guy back there helping him out
too and he's all tanky
it's like a multi-phase boss or multi
i don't know enemy
boss situation uh like a team you know
oh it's that one over there is open okay
yeah yeah oh so i just opened this one
got it okay
all right i've gotta try and get like
nine
oh [ __ ] i actually pop my super oh
one of the engrams just touched the
water
there's got to be a different thing
you're supposed to do to try and get
over there because
they just wreck you as you come in
okay who can i get oh what is this
oh is that just a mine he accidentally
stuck to the wall nice thank you
uh back in 18.
it doesn't seem like we can focus down
these other guys you think
it's kind of there's just like too many
enemies in the middle
no i'm good okay man thank you
okay i'm gonna try and get that scorch
cannon
well let's
maybe let's try to kill these guys who
are in the center
like yeah his uh his like acolytes or
whatever you know what i mean yeah
it's here i'm gonna get the one behind
us though so i'll at least
i'm shooting the
shank right now
oh
no this might be empty
yeah i think we got to clear these guys
before we can do this because we're
going to get killed up there
he's got the little
um
the mark where we could finish him
there we go all right yeah one of them's
dead okay i'm dropping now there's also
that vandal who's over there okay yeah
cool i think he's looking at me oh never
mind
nice oh i'm burning
all right i'm dropping off my three okay
there we go
nice okay not bad not bad let's try to
clear that other guy up
i'm getting killed by all these strikes
oh yeah you can't touch the water
yeah that's happened to me
okay i got that guy
nice oh you got the vandal hell yeah
yeah all right cool that [ __ ] that seems
much more doable
oh there's all there he dropped a bunch
yeah yeah
sick all right
okay yeah let's see if we can deposit
these
oh i'm getting cut apart all right thank
you good rift
whoa geez
all right i'm gonna activate another one
yeah let's okay nevermind we're over
there
okay here they come i got a whole mess
i'm gonna need cover but i can drop i'm
gonna drop off like 10. yeah me too
here i'm gonna throw a little healing
grenade in there for you guys oh thank
you that'd be beautiful
that's it
did we do it izzy he's up in the front
nice good walk well
also i don't know about you guys but
i've been getting uh my super back
really quickly um yeah whenever i pick
up greed
good dps
better than the third night bad not bad
all right thank you all right yep all
right no problem let's do one more okay
we got it
oh i love this i love this track dude
yeah it's so good
the swashbuckling like oh it's so nice
this is the one you can get from the
store that i mentioned earlier yeah that
you downloaded it's good okay dude
what you just said was so curious
because like i haven't missed kade in a
very long time but this does make me
genuinely miss him don't don't do
engrams yet let's clear the eye guys oh
sorry those no it's okay those the uh
big guys are back is all the tough guys
oh i see i see
i'm gonna i'll see what if i can do
these engrams that you did i was gonna
say i already got some so i'll just try
and yeah do it
i was i expected you're totally right
don't die
[Laughter]
okay cool
i'm out of heavies with real trouble
oh i got popped but i threw in ten as
well nice nice
okay um
i will probably die trying to save you
but
i'm gonna hit that shank
oh not bad golden gun hurt him pretty
bad
oh huge thank you let me get that uh
get the blinding grenades back out
even if i die
oh i got like half
rice
all right
oh no that that shank
uh i don't want to risk it i'm just
gonna wait for johnny to come back yeah
i got 13 seconds
there's a grenade right on your feet oh
nice okay i saw it
thank you though
right behind you
i got 20 seconds
i got you david
nice thank you
did you guys get the shank
no i think he's still up
i don't see him
i see him find him
okay
you know what would be a good guy it is
fastest way to take these guys down if
there's like a trick to it
supers are good i noticed i'm trying to
blind them and like so that's the one
thing about if we need a little bit of a
boost i'm pretty sure grabbing the greed
gives you more super energy
yeah so i i think maybe
it's worth getting them just to
get that super up
yeah have we tried hitting him with the
scorch cannons
as well
i have not yet
i haven't i get the feeling that won't
be much yeah
yeah i mean like the charge on the
scorch cannon takes forever to build up
is the thing
oh there they're coming out of it
also we
need another scorch cannon
oh here's one
yeah ask and you shall receive
okay
nope that one's not activated
where are those going to pop out on the
left or on the right there yeah okay
uh where all these stupid dregs are
anyway the uh the rotate around it
strategy worked pretty well so yeah yeah
yeah another bunch over on this side as
well if i can get to them
all right i dropped off five
oh damn
oh those locks loaded oh those exploded
yeah that sucks okay i'm gonna try and
get in there
that one's closed
okay
i'm about to die but i did get them all
in
yeah you're right it did it did pull up
a lot of super
seemingly
someone says this reminds some of the
goonies that's also another
man i have no heavy ammo and it's
killing me
ooh these blinding grenades are doing
work that was great
uh shanks down
nice dude nice
i don't know what happened to the vandal
dude
he's dead too i got him early nick all
right let's let's knock it out
yeah so we just gotta get some grass
okay i got a scorch cannon
it's over here by me
nice got it it did it everywhere
oh nice
[Music]
um i've only got four
i'm depositing these
that's it dps
i finally get some heavy
yeah i guess my heavy
oh shoot i should have uh
oh
excellent
keep going keep going keep going yeah
no you're fine you're fine
i shoot that it's going well
all right well
yeah we got him next time now we know
what we're doing this is great
good shape blind grenades hahaha
scorch can you guys in the front
cool all right i'm gonna get off this uh
grenade launcher
all right scorch cannons on me
okay
i'm getting them going
um okay where are they dropping oh no
dang it
i had a bunch but then i got immediately
killed god damn it
i didn't see any i i'm grabbing them all
okay we're trying to do that the others
are where my
body is
okay i'm gonna try to get to john luke
although i think they exploded by now
oh no i'm not worried about them i'm
worried about you
oh i blinded myself that was rough
okay
i got you
all right i dropped him like 18.
nice dude
there's a [ __ ] ton
that's why i popped the well down there
i was like i'm going to be here for a
minute like
nice
oh god that shank
stop
it's not cool
drew my best key that shouldn't be
blinded because he sucks
we're dropping everywhere
i think that might always be the case
oh shanks kick my ass
all right i'm headed to the middle
all right
head to the middle i'm gonna pop another
well down there
what's
next let's make sure we're like killing
these guys before we do that though
i don't want to dps with them shooting
at us yeah uh i just think yeah we got
the shane
yeah shanks down nice nice nice is the
other
oh i see the candle
come on crawl on i almost got it oh
there we go there he is
oh you dropped a bunch nice
oh don't die john lee oh don't die
oh thank you for that rift running yeah
trying to draw fire okay oh you're a
little bomb okay we just need to do
another one i think and we're good yep
all right i got a scorch cannon i got my
super up
dope all right yeah we're set
in fact i'll head to the middle so we're
all in the same place okay
okay here we go
i'm coming with 10.
me too
that's it
all right here we go we can finish them
[Music]
[Music]
all right background
oh i asked luna
oh i got a bunch of the um
uh the thorn uh
armor
oh yeah the corrupting
look who's over here
who's that oh it's lobster wilhelm
luke he's got a peg
[Laughter]
not
leg
no way oh my god here's a lure item
i love that uh where's the lure item
it's right next to him yeah it's just on
him
oh okay
okay what's this arbor
oh heck yeah
oh man
good times look at my dumb beanie on top
of my uh
my armor
i gotta transmog this armor [ __ ] asap
yeah yeah this armor is sick
oh man
all right ggs let me see this ice luna
got this please be something good yeah
outlaw headstone i don't think i got any
uh any weapons
no i just got the armor
nice work guys yeah gg all right so
what's actually what's going on with the
quest
uh the quest good question go back to
shahan
we gotta bring the wolf pack round
to shaw
all right and
we should just get gallahorn it's not
guessing yet i guess okay
no there's multiple more cool steps
actually
oh my god it's only two of eight jesus
[Laughter]
uh i'm gonna go to the bathroom while we
fly i'll be right back all right
perfect
all right well
we can go a little bit longer on the
stream but we uh we'll call it
soon-ish so uh we'll probably not get
all the way through the galahorn uh
quest if that's the case on the stream
but we'll we'll do a little bit more
gal horn's cool but i want that i want
that halo pistol
it's a sidearm so i wonder
but i'm still like but it's the halo
pistol
if only it worked like the the halo
pistol in reach because that thing's
legit they're sorry not reach infinite
can't talk
and do i have the ability to transmog do
i have i think i have enough
all right whoops whoa above my desk and
everything shook
i do excellent
nice
i'm afraid of my postmaster right now
oh yeah it's getting it's getting dicey
there's a lot of dialogue
mm-hmm a lot of texts
found this on the loo grave
david you're still there
yeah i'm here i'm on discord right now
messaging some folks about the dungeon
gotcha man
all right let's see what you shot and
now it's time for
killing randos we gotta go kill
defeat powerful fallen in the cosmodrome
okay we lost everything the last time
interesting
what counts as a powerful just any major
yeah okay
should we just do uh
um
we could do a lost
sector that's probably yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's true
we should um
we should do like one of the oh [ __ ] is
it like a mass or legend by chance here
this week no no no no ah bummer
yeah but no yeah we can just farm a lost
sector
let's just do the one that's uh behind
us
yeah
yeah yeah i'm coming back for the first
time in a long time
that was a pretty neat dungeon
yeah i think the thing was is that it it
parts of it lacked the
initial like grandeur of something from
like prophecy however
their prophecy was like
really incredible the first couple times
but then it like kind of dragged for me
a little bit
only because
like the some of the encounters were
just so arduous like the [ __ ] cube
room and yeah the rainbow road you know
it was just like too long whereas this
one
but it takes forever it takes forever
yeah and whereas this one at first i was
kind of like
but
i'm imagining grinding this dungeon out
for the next you know however many weeks
and it feels like it won't get stale
because it's nice and like kind of those
encounters are a little bit piecemeal
like that sparrow section is so just
short and sweet and exhilarating like
totally and once you know where the
traps are it's gonna go quick yeah
i think the the the key room or whatever
the like unlocking
the things that could be a bit of a pain
sometimes only for like chasing stuff
down but yeah but like once we know
we're like okay we're looking for these
uh turrets we're looking for these
servers it's just gonna like you know
click through so fast
yeah that was uh those are really great
uh someone's asking in the chat if
moments of triumph uh is available yet
it is oh shoot yeah it is seals up
i can just
knock out real quick
oh yeah this is an exotic sparrow
hey look at that and a shell oh that's a
nice looking shell um let's see
win rounds of trials of osiris a few
guardians bosses
final bosses in terms of eternity it
looks like you do dare a bunch of times
uh yeah a lot there
yeah kind of like a little bit of empire
hunts i gotta do more empire hunts oh
yeah unlocked a t-shirt
[Laughter]
gg bungee
yeah i did too
hell
yeah let me look at this uh ghost shell
that's a cool looking shell
i like that
and then sparrow
that's also a cool looking sparrow
yeah it seems like the moment stuff this
year is cool yeah and moments you don't
need to um
uh
pay for that either right that's also
free right
although i guess uh some of the stuff is
tied to the dungeon so i guess if you
want to have it all you would need to
get the dungeon right
ooh that grasp of avarice okay yeah that
council is not powerful emblem is pretty
dope
oh yeah look at that yeah
one second while i get that guy oh i'm
sure
i think mine got sent to the post office
freaking pirates man
i want pirate armor
yeah yeah give me pirate armor dude
the peg leg yes
let's steal that guy's piglet there we
go at least at least like turn our leg
into a peg leg for an emote or something
you know
did you just zap him with your sword
i'm not entirely sure what happened
there
i don't even look at it it looks like
you electrocuted them for my screen that
was crazy
uh
did that drop no composure
one up here i it is an ark sword so i
guess i guess that is what it did
dude no composure is so good what the
hell
i was messing around with salvagers
again the other day god i love that
thing
another wolf pack on me nice yeah i
think we're all getting him
oh do you get it if i just pick it up
yeah
that is convenient i think so also i
didn't want to distract but i was using
rat king during that last encounter
and it was very helpful dude
i think it's a dick man we gotta i gotta
finish that catalyst i need help that's
how i was getting some of those
rematches i just went i just went
[ __ ] in this
yeah i was wondering why you were
invisible
oh i'm not getting i'm not getting these
you guys are getting more of them i'm
not
really
no
weird
uh yeah that's i'm at five of seven
already i only got two
what's going on what
well maybe shoot more guys maybe it's
final blows
yeah maybe these final blows are like
contributing to the uh damage or
something yeah yeah we're just getting
enough
yeah it's annoying
make sure you put a little hurt on that
boss yeah yeah there you go
okay yeah that one i got
okay sick
i wasn't
see that's weird yeah yeah it must be it
must be making sure you hit him that
might be something we'll see on a
like destiny player support thing yeah
where it's like oh sometimes only two
out of three
there's like four heavy bricks that's
right
what
okay glitchy
what is
[Laughter]
yeah
how do we exit this uh
back here
they all lead back to each other i've
all i've always only done this for
legend and master so like it would just
there'd be a timer to end the right
the thing
yeah i love how they loop though
it's like so such a nice intricate
little design yeah we're at the
beginning again yeah yeah i gotta go so
just keep walking back
i thought i saw a guy was like oh did it
respawn them already
oh we gotta go hunt down all that lore
okay that should be enough right i gotta
yeah i think so i gotta plug in a
controller and put on the battle rifle
just like to feel feel live feel feel
the halo
i do like that vr
it's it's fun and that and the trace
rifle is really [ __ ] fun the trace
rifle is really cool shoot make sure
everybody touches that guy before we
kill him
oh uh i'm behind you guys one sec
i mean actually we're i'm pretty close
so it doesn't really matter
yeah okay yeah we're good
not get one did knock out
did not get one either
it's just goofy rng
yeah maybe yeah or it's a little wonky
also that we've had surprisingly few
problems for the first day of new
content one over here
nope didn't get one there
oh now i got one
okay
this is so weird
it says you collect them which implies
they like drop
i haven't seen anything but i haven't
seen any drops i don't i don't know
all right that's how we're going
one more
nope i haven't gotten any
rough
oh okay okay all right yeah i'm done
with mine
i'm not
yeah keep going
you get to kill all these bosses
okay that one gave me one
nice
yeah we should just let you like finish
them all yeah just kill everything i
feel like the finishers finishers are
like a does it
[Laughter]
that's genuinely perfectly summed that
up just
did not get one from that guy more heavy
emma
what is up with the headphones
just
[ __ ] flying out oh i love it it's so
funny yeah this is so goofy dude
oh man
uh where is
honestly i'll just try running through
it by myself really quick and see if
yeah yeah we got that
that's better
now that that works that works for me
i'll i'll just hang out with uh with
shaw yeah we gotta go talk to shaw
anyway so
all right i see
oh well i wasn't gonna talk too i'm just
gonna hang out by him go ahead a cool
new friend
hey man it's sean han i look up to him
everyone loves shahan
the legendary shah
where is my
okay that one give me one okay now we
get rocket house over getting parts okay
targeting system our housing holds you
so
looks like we're going to the tower
so yeah there are eight steps but
they're not
several of them are talk to banshee talk
to you
so now that i'm uh by myself i've been
getting them reliably so i think it's
just
don't do it as a party kind of thing
i can just kill this guy he'll be good
yep all right cool
did i just have to go back to him
all right
here to help
oh my god so much text jesus
yeah he's got a lot to say and they
didn't want to do voice
right
okay go to banshee
all right we all gonna go the tower
i'm gonna check my postmaster and get
some of those
sick emblems
all these all these emblems for moments
are cool
nightfall strikes
trails of science wow yeah
yeah it's kind of nice that
they're
asking for more like strikes and gamut
though because i have to do them for um
[Music]
to get that stupid rocket launcher
ornament on both of them so it's like
all right yeah yeah i feel i feel i feel
better about
trying to go for that track oh damn
that's i got a lot my postmaster
i got a full auto and one two punch
ratador that might be fun
a transaction to make guardian
actually the very first one that dropped
i think might be the one
where is it
it's oh this one's full auto too and
tricorn
and range masterwork
all right
oh damn i think this might be a good
perk combo
oh [ __ ]
so i got the trace rifle
the halo looking one with um
genesis which usually i like go aim for
but since trace rifles use special ammo
and breaking a shield for special ammo
like regenerates it
so it's just like free but then also the
second trade is gold and tricorn
uh which is like final blows with this
weapon grant bonus damage and while the
buff is active grenade or melee kills
with the same damage type greatly
increase his damage and duration so it
sounds like just running a solar
monster in pve with this thing could be
really fun
oh my god you're not going to believe it
we have to go back to that exact locked
law sector we were just in
that is incredible
uh
we're kind of cranking through this
though assuming we're good if we could
hurry we can maybe get this before the
end of the stream
yeah let's do it i mean this this last
sector goes quick no big deal yeah all
right uh if you guys are good i'm just
going to take us back there
yeah let's do it
that's so funny and this is the last
step bill because the last one will be
oh no we're on six yeah we're six so
there's two more steps two more steps
one of them will definitely be talk to
whoever gives it to you yeah exactly
claim your prize basically
oh it's behind us what
oh yeah
i totally gung-ho'd the wrong way
man 30th annie
this week halo infinite this week what a
good
good week
what a good week man
and you know i
fortnight's done but also i've been
enjoying it
i jumped in with the new map i've got
some friends who are like
suddenly got really into fortnite mostly
because the skins are dumb and it's kind
of like yeah spiderman
i saw people swing the the spiderman
thing and i was like man that actually
seems pretty fun that actually looks
pretty good
i'll play with you phil i'll play for
you
yeah i mean like what's what's fun about
it is it's very much like a who cares if
we win kind of situation right yeah it's
just a dumb game
i mean the big thing for me is like
looking at that spider-man thing and
being like oh
man that just really knocks the sail out
of uh the avengers yeah
dude oh my god like everyone was waiting
for that and then it happened it's like
the costumes look cool and you know but
like the swinging looked really like
awkward cs1 era spider-man like
you're like
the environments are just not built for
that in avengers you know like there is
a lot of cool traversal in avengers but
it's not like spider-man style it's like
platforms
right right
[Music]
but then fortnite just comes in and says
like little jk here you go spider-man
can swing anywhere who cares yeah it's
like fortnite's mmo it's like four
nights at mo to just plagiarize other
people and do it better i mean that's
just a coincidence there's no way but
for sure it's like yeah fortnight's
holding but just pop in and then just
like
mess up your day
[ __ ] fortnite man
it's so goofy
there's a post that uh what's his face
from
uh gears of war and epic like cliff
lizinski or whatever yeah the goo the
goofball he uh but he made a point that
was really interesting where he was like
hey it's kind of weird to see epic
like own
basically a license
and then sell that license and then have
to like sublease it back
for [ __ ] fortnight to like throw it
in it's just like a weird coincidence
oh that is weird
you know what i mean like rebuy or
re-release the the property to get
marcus phoenix in fortnite
that's
that's so weird
that is weird
time is a circle yeah
but also they have so much money now
that they're like uh whatever
they're like who cares
because yeah at first i was totally like
wait no they own they made gears of war
they should be able to i was like right
microsoft owns it
yeah
oh that guy went down fast
[Laughter]
okay now we go to uh back to shaw
cool
wait a minute
did you get the charging system
what step are you guys on
you have to did you open the loot box
here at the end
all right guys uh i never talked to
banshee oh my god
[Applause]
and i will
i will see you guys in like five minutes
maybe
well let's we can at least finish it on
this yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna finish it
up on the stream right yeah you you do
your thing all right completed
talk to shaw hand to complete california
nice oh man
that is that is funny nice work nice
work
all right
oh it didn't it doesn't do it no no you
gotta you gotta go over here and uh
oh you got it first you gotta do it yeah
you have to go over there and then you
talk to him
anyway yes
i have a bunch of chests in here
whoa pay 20 000 glimmer what did i just
open oh weird old stuff
that's weird that's it anyway that's
galahorn reassemble components
go sick it on some like dregs or
something yeah just go
yeah dude
oh man
sick dude
okay so that's actually a pretty easy
quest i was really concerned uh that
you know we we did the dungeon and then
they were like you got six more steps
and i'm like oh no but honestly
that's extremely straightforward
the jungle is definitely the big the big
yeah that's the only real big part
oh yeah oh
it's pretty
[Music]
you see there's a nerf one
i think they just tweeted about it they
just tweeted about it like a minute ago
they made they actually made a nerf gal
horn yeah
oh my god let's look into it
i read this floor
all right well
i think that's what we're going to call
it
we didn't shoot something with him real
quick hang on we got gallon i mean i
shot something
well let me shoot something all right if
you go shoot something with it
we'll go watch phil shoot something with
it
where's literally any enemy oh my god
they're like nine guys over here yeah
they're all doing a um
a public event
oh my god
right here phil
ah yes
oh
yeah so how does it work
i'm not a hundred percent
sure you're not like you're not how does
california work
i mean it's just
uh it's just you know once it
i think it's just yeah once it explodes
it just
and everybody was so densely packed that
i couldn't see
the little backgrounds coming out and
stuff oh yeah yeah i can see it
happening yeah
nice okay
gg everybody that was a lot of fun hell
yeah
haskell says as much as i love that it's
back i ain't paying 25 for it you know
what
that's fair i don't pay 25 for that
dungeon that dungeon is cool that
dungeon is cool but i i totally
understand when it where i think
everyone's going to kind of come up to
their own uh conclusions on what's worth
spending their money on so i think
that's fair
uh yeah for those of you who do end up
getting this hope you have a good time
for those of you who don't i hope you
also have a good time with whatever else
we're gonna
we gotta take this over to atheon see
see what happens
see how it goes yeah i think like in the
trailer they put up today they literally
showed like people firing it at atheon
six of them
uh all right guys well we're gonna call
it there uh thanks for tuning in
watching uh and we hope to see you uh
next time
catch y'all yeah thanks
you